it's just a day it's just a day you know
we can do it it's just today I think I
think we can do it happy new years
having new years think about that a new
year think about a calendar now think
about another calendar and that's where
we are you know what I'm saying that
that crispy little calendar Oh is
scratching its neck out again
it's yawn you weary I have a friend he
Spanish dude or Mexican and he he'll say
oh is he on you a tea and I love that I
love that's one thing that I do enjoy
about different languages is it's more
you know when you say something a
different language it's like your tongue
gets to do something special you know
like January that just sounds like and
it's something you know somebody
probably gonna get you know shot you
know the mail is gonna be late you know
somebody might get you know a rash or a
little bit of you know maybe even a
little bit of aids up around their neck
or something you know by you know skin
AIDS or whatever measles but you say oh
it's Yan you a tea
[Music]
anything could happen in Yan you any
young you a tea you might have a party
you know I'm saying you might just you
might find gold you ever found gold yeah
well you you know this could be that
time so happy young Yamane Happy New
Year's you feel me no fears baby it's
that cat daddy I'm back come on
I'm that dreadlocked flamingo you got it
you know Sam I'm that Rasta that yard
bird you see me over in a distance
standing up on one leg with that pink
body coat huffing on that yet
huffing on that yeah you know what's up
baby it's that nutmeg donkey coming at
you 2019 we can do it and we can start
right now
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wandering how could I be so far and my
mind is somewhere else but when I found
it I'll patch up where it's been grown
happy new years guys and girls what's
cool for me to sell that pocket break
and let myself all my shine allow me
[Music]
I'll sit and tell you my story
breathe happy new year and this is it
and it is a special time know it's funny
a new year it's that you know it's I
mean la be honest it's the same year as
before but it's just really a chance to
kind of restart reconnect I feel you
know you can evaluate look at your body
that's one thing I do you know I'll do
this a lot of guys don't like to do this
you know a lot of guys don't like to
look at their body as we get older you
know women women will speak often about
their body and this and that and you
know something's happening and they got
this or whatever but men a lot of times
we have body problem you know your body
starts to look you know special you know
I was at a Christmas meal and somebody I
don't think it was a family member but
somebody that was you know kind of
[ __ ] somebody that was in our family
so it was like a lover you know where
something was at the house and this
fella had a big mole back behind his
right in that little soft spot behind
you know on the back of your knee behind
your knee whatever that little it's like
a little joint where you if you know
behind your knee the other side of your
knee whatever that's called that little
it's almost like where if your knee had
like a little butthole kind of that's
where it would be you know or a bee hole
I'm sorry
I don't want to say you know say well I
gotta say it again just to tell you what
I said but I don't want to say butthole
again this early in the new year but
yeah if your if your knee had a little
bee hole that would be in that soft spot
on the back side of your of your knee on
the back ear leg
and this gentleman had a damn mole back
there looked like a damn I mean just
like a damn chocolate elevator button
you know like if he was at the Chocolate
Factory and you wanted to go all the way
to the top you would press this big
brown hitter so all the kids at the
house kept kind of running up and press
on old boys you know hitting him on that
little I mean it was big to look like a
damn second base you know if you ever
played baseball or something if you ever
play baseball sometimes you will be
running around the bases and the bases
are things out of the ground and those
are bases and they're white but this
fella looked like he had a damn second
base back there made out of just mold
and just you know little chunks of uh
you know body cancer but all the kids
kept coming up and just ringing that
[ __ ] like a doorbell you know so this
is the time of year where as men we have
to do something for ourselves we have to
evaluate you got to look at yourself
get that gander you know get a mirror if
you don't have a mirror you know get you
some strong tinfoil you know or some
aluminum foil that has a real you know
kind of a robust attitude and put that
[ __ ] out and get a look at yourself take
stock take inventory look at your body
where you got some new hair at my buddy
didn't realize he had damn he had like
six inches of hair on his try on the
back side of his triceps he didn't see
it because he hadn't taken a little bit
of that body inventory and get that
gander at yourself and you know next
thing you know he could cornrow his
[ __ ] triceps do you know and that's
really a beautiful art if you haven't
seen some of that that's real Native
American or kind of something maybe like
you know kind of young you know kind of
inner-city girls will do before they
jump rope you know braid it'll do
braiding but it's a time or you look at
your body you know get over about a mere
bend
over check your body check your but you
know look at the back of your nuts see
who's back there what's going on if you
have a tattoo back there I'm behind you
nuts or something do you remember
getting that do you have a rash you know
I knew a gal one time and uh she showed
everybody that you know that little baby
badger hole and our party and she didn't
realize she had a bunch of big mumps or
something back there
there's something you know Big Damn you
know some he's some real booty mumps or
something back there back there by that
little booty hole be whole sorry
damn I keep saying it and I don't want
to say it and I'm sorry that I said it
already a couple times but yeah you got
to be careful you got to know what's
going on man and it's special especially
for us you got to check your nuts check
your nuts and they say you can't feel
your body at work I'm not touching
myself sir okay I'm checking my body for
cancer so if your boss comes up you know
my boss one time I was well this
actually I was you know it was actually
I was you know you know kind of enjoying
my body one time I worked that up what
was that place called chefs chefs boy Oz
or something chefs voyage and it was a
real [ __ ] and I was a humble it was
nice they had real nice silverware I
mean the kind of silverware you looked
at it you were like damn did this you
know am I on the Titanic but you were
just in a shopping mall you were over
there by payless shoes really so if you
looked out the window you would know you
weren't on the Titanic but if the
windows were closed and you were just
staring at the silverware you could
maybe have the idea you were boating but
anyway I worked up there and my buddy
worked up there and he was homoerotic
you know he preferred the company of men
and men's bodies but anyway he was about
40 or something and he was a you know he
was also a real he was a boxer he was
like a real uh you know kind of this
little a Tao
he looked kind of you know he looked
like a little he looked like a kind of a
senior citizen but also like a child at
the same time he was that kind of mixed
Italian daddy you know that mozzarella
madman and his name was Billy conforto
rest in peace because he ate a bunch of
pills years later and he drove a car in
a new arm embankment out there in
Laplace Louisiana and he was uh he was a
good friend of mine and we got stoned
one time during when Princess Diana died
and I didn't know what Princess Diana
was you know I thought it was you know a
beanie baby or like a nice dessert and
we'd gone over to his house because he
was my friend you know we were actually
really good friends and we were close
friends and and I miss him and he uh and
he would he had made us a couple chicken
cutlets you know grilled us up a couple
of you know hearty chicken breasts I
mean a real chicken not one of these
weak [ __ ] that they're pumping all
these vitamins and and riboflavin Zin
two over there and you know out there in
Laurel Mississippi but I'm talking about
them real bad boys I'm talking about the
kind of chicken that gets up in the
morning does some you know does some
lunges and does some uh you know work
does uh you know maybe 40 pounds of
incline press I'm talking about that
kind of chicken that real that [ __ ]
bad [ __ ] it'll sing you know I'm saying
I'm talking about uh maybe a black
chicken you know kind of lady that'll be
singing in the you know singing in the
chorus in the yard while the other
chickens just doing some [ __ ] I'm
talking about a real bad [ __ ] and he
had some of those cutlets those high-end
cutlets and he grilled those headers up
and we had gotten stoned doing drugs you
know doing uh marijuana and we got so
stoned man and we arm and that's when
Princess Diana died and he kept telling
me and I don't know what the [ __ ] he is
talking about dude I thought he was
talking about a damn beanie baby and I
was [ __ ] up but anyhow he and I worked
together at a place and they
caught me one time in about in a freezer
section in the freezer you know they had
bread pudding in the freezer not sneaked
back there and do a couple whippets and
had me a couple of [ __ ] quick
handfuls of bread pudding and if you've
ever worked at a restaurant you know
what I'm talking about it's called
taking a break and that was something we
would do and I get back there and hit
them whippets get me for [ __ ] you
know and get get feeling all kind of
creamy up in my skull and then I fill my
mouth with that just god damn I don't
know if you've ever had a little bit of
bread pudding and eating it out of your
own hand but that is the damn Lord's
tartare right there boy yeah dang some
people when they die you know they want
to be embalmed or they want to you know
you know they want their family to shoot
him out of a cannon or something into a
damn you know into a damn you know
school yard or they want to be you know
putting up in one of them
what are those lava lamps but this was
uh what I'm talking about is when you
die [ __ ] what am I talking about
oh I'm talking about that bread pudding
I'm talking about this the kind of [ __ ]
when I die I want to be embalmed with
that bread pudding and poured a little
bit of that [ __ ] raisin sauce on my
body that bourbon just that bourbon back
wall just dip daddy's ass in that
bourbon backwash and you put me in a
casket like that you gonna see how many
people come to my funeral
that's what I'm saying this Adam this
funeral is five-star this is a Michelin
five-star funeral baby and goddamn
what's that boy on is he was he he
smells good
he smelled like he's got that rum raisin
sauce on him and that's how I want to
die I want to be embalmed with bread
pudding like a real man
like a real man but Billy conforto was
one of the first real men that I ever
met my life and he was you know he was
good to me he was protective of me and
he you know when other kids would do me
wrong he would fight them and I guess in
hindsight it's a little weird to think a
35 year old man was fighting children
but you know where I grew up that was
what it was what it was you know I'm
saying age didn't really matter you
would just fight each other you know you
see a six-year-old and a [ __ ] 82 year
old out there just you know out there
beating each other in the neck with you
know kind of small pieces of wood lean
pieces of wood swap swaths so but man he
you know we were good buddies and what
happened was I worked over there at that
restaurant and what am I talking about I
don't even know well Happy New Year guys
that's what I'm saying and Happy New
Year girls and we are you know we're we
just we're just deciding who we are
still it's that year where you can kind
of reimagine yourself a little and I
think it has to start in your
imagination in your brain in that little
thought aquarium this you know catching
that free ride on top of your neck
because your neck the only reason you
have a neck is to [ __ ] put your brain
out up in the air a little bit otherwise
your brain would just be kind of right
down between your shoulders think about
that all your neck is is like a little
damn vase for your brain and eyes so but
this is a time here where we can we I
think if you want to kind of read and
not reinvent yourself but you can
reimagine yourself it's like you know
life is just still going forward but
suddenly somebody walks up with a piece
of chalk and they just draw like a line
in front of you
and sometimes a line is so powerful you
know because it can be a starting point
it can be an ending point you know I'm
drawing the line right here this is the
starting line right here it can connect
to things I got a how do I get from here
to here oh I know how alive you know a
line is such a simple thing and it can
be so powerful so this is that time of
year where you can set your line you
could set your line what do you want to
catch what do you want to reel in do you
want anything different you just want to
keep riding the same you want to walk
that tightrope and a tightrope that's
just a line it's time to just you know
set your line and we can do it and
that's one thing is beautiful about this
time of year is it's just a chance to
kind of read yes you know you could turn
the gas off for a little bit and now you
can restart relight the pilot you know
whatever happened happened and now I'm
gonna I'm gonna put this line right here
and when I walk over the line I'm gonna
try something different I'm gonna try to
have a new experience for myself that's
one thing I'm thinking about oh dude I
had a good we had New Year's Eve at the
world-famous Comedy Store on the Sunset
Strip and I got to be the headliner and
it's kind of crazy like last year I was
the I was just on the bill I got to be
on the show and David Spade's was a
headliner and David Spade's is like a
he's like a child actor but he's now a
man but he still is really a child actor
that plays the role of men and he and I
just got to be on the bill and it was
exciting and it was adventurous and it
was you know a fun night but this time
you know I got to be the headliner
dude was pretty cool to see you know
people were excited and it was good
energy we put up a video on patreon if
you're a patreon or you can check it out
on there of the some of the backstage
and just the experience and and it was
fun you know and we did the - we did the
toast at midnight and a lot of times to
toast somebody you know we'll fight you
know you have Italian guy or like you
know stab somebody in the neck with
their wine glass you know you'll have
you know maybe one of your Jewish
buddies will leave early and kind of
chirp out on a tab or whatever you know
of sometime a blackout completely
they'll all roll out then just you know
no tab and um and you know if things can
happen around midnight you know maybe
some white do might sneak over with a
long mustache and see and steal wha
somebody's arm you know still a little
ten of Altoids or something you know
that's like a hipster crime isn't it
hipsters be doing [ __ ] like that they're
gonna sneak over there and steal a
little tin of Altoids or something
[ __ ] wild cats a hipster is crazy man
a hipster while you sleep and they'll
come over and gel down your body hair
and steal your wallet like what the [ __ ]
man they're wild like that and they'll
come over and smell your breath and try
to try to tell your future like what
dude I've had you know just I had a
couple mozzarella sticks don't be you
know predicting a bunch of wild [ __ ] but
that's how they are sometimes different
people at midnight some people turn into
a [ __ ] wolf if you have a friend that
turned you know he's kind of haired up
or something some [ __ ] Persian bad
boy he might turn into a [ __ ] wolf
and jump out the window
you know him buy a Mercedes so you just
you know different people behave
differently at midnight but that
everybody just was really calm we had a
nice cheers we casually brought in the
New Year and then we got right back into
the show so I'm grateful to everybody
that came out I really am and it was fun
a lot of nice people I met after the
show some people had driven in from
different places
I met a pair of brothers that had flown
in from Wyoming a man it just really
lifted up my spirits you know uh you
know and sometimes I feel bad in my life
that I you know that I haven't really
gone out of my way that much at some
moments but that meant a lot that you
know these boys flew in from Wyoming
actually they weren't brothers every
damned cousins and I told him they were
brothers I said you guys need to you
know spit into a cup and mail it in or
you know jerk off onto a Dalmatian and
see what it's you know see if it knows
anything but you guys might be damn
brothers because they look like [ __ ]
brothers man but just good people a lot
of good people came out and I'm super
grateful for everybody they came out and
I sold out two shows or we sold out two
shows on New Year's Eve at the
world-famous Comedy Store on Sunset
Boulevard in Los Angeles and if you'd
have told the kid you know that was
walking down McGee Street over there in
Covington Louisiana you know uh just
with you know just fury and his in his
brain and if you'd have told that boy
and just uncertainty and you know
probably feeling less than but feeling
you know like there could be some
potential and energy in the world and
excitement and hope and just all those
young that chasm of just that ROYGBIV of
[ __ ] feelings that a young boy has if
you'd have told that kid man you were
gonna get to live out and at least some
moments that will make you feel that
will make you feel okay that will make
you that you will find some joy in or
you'll get to live out a dream even if
it's just for a moment
man it's it was really really nice man
it was a lot of fun so thank you to
everybody that came out to that oh I got
to tell you this so I went to a hair
show they got a hair company in a hair
company they sell a hair company they
sell not
not knives scissors and they're called
hands oh and the man told me they said
have you heard a hands oh and I was like
hands oh I was like is that I think
that's where he when you're driving you
take both your hands off the wheel and
somebody in the passenger seat
hopefully a hitchhiker you know sprays
you out a little you know get you to
kind of come a little with their hand
and Nessebar that's what it used to mean
and he said nah nah man it's different
now it's um it's a scissor company and
they make strong scissors you know hair
knives because hair knives a long time
ago if you were in a special country or
in a foreign land somebody come up real
quick you give him a dollar they'll
[ __ ] just salt you know they saw you
up
they Ginsu they you know and next thing
you know you walk out an air you know
keyed up looking like a damn cockatiel
like a couple raccoons might try to [ __ ]
you because you got that beautiful that
suave hitter on top of your head that
follicle fianc you know that follicle
fiancée nests bro and that's 100%
fiancée damn he looking as snazzy that
boy is fiancée and and that's what this
company they make spicy scissors they
make the kind of scissor man you cut
your hair and next thing you know you're
[ __ ] you know you with the Lord and
you feeling right in your heart like
damn they just and you know and I didn't
know a lot about hair styling you know I
cut my own hair tall's probably maybe 32
and then now I see a man about it and I
go to a basic man a barbershop my guy's
a by cyclist he does bicycling on the
weekends to you know to get away from
his family because he's like that you
know he's a parent but man I walked in
this place dude I'll say this hair
stylist and people in the hair gained
their wild bro these people had so much
like the craziest swag I've ever seen
you know just saw like you see a dude
they would all
they were all meticulously quaffed and
styled you see a dude he had a beard bro
but inside he had a little bird living
in the beer like right in the front
another dude he his beard had two little
doors on it you open him up and then a
little thing we come out and tell you it
was lunchtime you know a little you know
alarm bird or something like all kind of
wild [ __ ] they had to do wearing an urn
around his neck he had his cousin around
his neck like what the [ __ ] but he could
have left a little Jeremy at home you
know but people was swagged out you had
it dude he had his sideburn right he
grown it all it went down his neck and
connected
he had that cheer that cheered you know
where your chest and your beard hair
just goes there ain't no stop in us and
that [ __ ] just connects and it was a
full line all the way down to his pubis
or purpose you know all the way down it
was kind of public area and it was just
a full like a sideburn and then it went
all the way down to that side urine baby
and that thing starts to yearn for that
that see rocks you know down there so
people was just you know they have one
dude he had a cousin his little cousin
he had him wrapped around his neck like
a scarf he had a real flexible cousin
you know the boy did yoga and all of
that he was wearing him like a damn
shawl around his head and I had to
perform at this place and I'm like well
what the what what am I gonna do
these people were fired up you know
these people are [ __ ] selling
scissors man and they're keyed up and
they they all got all kind of swag some
you know somebody was drinking uh they
was doing all kind of stuff you know
somebody had a little um you know uh had
a little uh like a dozen eggs around her
neck on a little piece of rope what the
[ __ ] is that man what is that
but people was swagged up well you know
people had a tattoos of all kind of
stuff people had a bunch of you know
Trail of Tears going up and down their
arm and some dude had a lightning bolt
you know coming right out of his eye
socket some dude had a toaster oven
plugged into his back it was like a
tattoo like what the [ __ ]
you know people keyed up people thinking
about breakfast and how to perform at
this place and it was it was next level
man and I thought I had some swag but I
had it nothing compared to these hanzo's
the hands o people that sells pay or
knives you know it scissors and I was
like I've you know I've done a little
scrapbooking you know that but nothing
like this nothing like this
what else what was that thing oh dude I
was thinking about this bro maps aren't
that great anymore go look at a map
dude look what's on it mountains
mountains
um what is like a wet on slippery kind
of river all kind of stuff on it but not
the [ __ ] we need man I need a real map I
need to know where the cocaine is at
okay can we get that on the map okay um
what's the map company Merriam web
merriam-webster whatever it is Psalms
but we need a map with real [ __ ]
where's the [ __ ] quicksand y'all
putting toes on the map I don't give a
[ __ ] about rock Plateau I want to know
where are all these [ __ ] that's just
gonna be trying to get at you for your
money where is that area where is the
people that think they're better than
everybody else can we outline those
areas around the edges at a country like
I'm on a real map like where you where
are you most likely to see twins
wouldn't that be helpful because if you
riding across the country in a car or
van or something you know or even
hang-gliding or something really far you
want to be able to know where you might
be able to you know land and see some
twins cuz that's the kind of [ __ ] that's
helpful but now they got all this [ __ ]
here's a map you know here's a Plateau
I don't give a dang here's a National
Forest what about uh where there's
possible gold how about that let's make
a map that's actually helpful what about
where people have asthma and what about
where you know where people most likely
to you know get bit by sharks or rabies
how about showing the damn rabies belt
how about putting stuff on a map that is
helpful to people oh here's an um
tributary I don't give a [ __ ] where's
little Terry that's always slinging em
eight-balls you feel me Wayne he on the
map and we need new maps dude and I'll
say that right now so mr. Trump why
don't you give us some new maps but I
wouldn't mind a map let me know where I
could get the freshest milk because if
you notice a lot of the milk you get
especially if you get milk at a gas
station that [ __ ] is the it is the Bruce
Willis of leche you have to that should
go sour in eight hours you have eight
hours to drink any milk you get from a
gas station go fall asleep as soon as
you wake up that milk will be sour you
know we need we need to legalize decent
gas station milk but it's a new year
it's a new time what am i doing this
year that's gonna be different
still struggling to quit smoking
ah man I'm tired of it I'm gonna to
actually seek some kind of real help
about it because I don't do it much but
I just can't stop and I hate it
you know I hate being us I hate it I
just hate it
um what else you know I'm trying you
know I'm just I'm almost let me see I
might be a month off of pornography so
that I'm feeling pretty good about not
seeing that kind of visuals you know
then body visuals and see people showing
their booty and stuff like that and it's
time of year still like I said to get
into checking out your own body and
looking at yourself and knowing what's
going on where do you have mucus where
do you have mumps because you might have
a booty bump or something on you and you
want to get that bit shaved down you
know it's that time of year shave your
booty down Jen you wear a I'll tell you
this I'm gonna be an Irvine I'm gonna be
an Irvine I'm gonna be an Omaha at the
Omaha funnybone that those stores are
sold out and that's going to be this
weekend then next weekend I'm going to
be an Irvine Friday Saturday and Sunday
I'm excited about that who else we got
some some cool cats we'll be in the
crowd there I'm excited Addison improv
that just sold-out that's at the end of
January and then Columbus Houston Boston
Atlantic City San Jose those are all
coming up and Phoenix all through the
end of March and Kansas City in April
all those tickets are believed available
at theof on Comm slashed or tou our
today's episode is brought to you by
grey block pizza and gray block is a
snazzy slice and if you ever wanted to
put a shape in your mouth that also has
flavor go to grey block
cuz they got them triangular Fiasco's
and they'll put it right up in your face
and make you feel fully Italian gray
block pizza get that hitter
this past weekend has also brought to
you by Skillshare men I love this
company Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with more than
25,000 classes in design business and
more you'll discover countless ways to
fuel your curiosity creativity and
career take classes in social media
marketing mobile photography creative
writing or even illustration whether
you're looking to discover a new passion
or start a side hustle or gain
professional skills Skillshare is there
to help you keep learning and thriving
I'm going to thank everybody that has
used skills here so many of our
listeners I got it for some of my family
members for Christmas you can join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today this past weekend
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for free that's right Skillshare is
offering this past weekend listeners two
months that's two months of unlimited
access to over 25,000 classes for free
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
Theo von th EO vo n again go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo von to start
your two months now if there's something
you need to get into a new career you
don't have to go get these big degrees
anymore you just need to have the skill
set and you can get a skill set at
Skillshare dot-com and you might just
find stuff that inspires you you know
even if you just want to learn how to do
social media better that sort of thing
you can change it you can change things
fast man I got that gristle in my throat
a little you know now it's making a list
the other day of
of all the people that I bet that have
helped me in my life you know it's
trying to I'm trying to get more in a
gratitude this year and I really want to
[Music]
you know I really want to be I want to
be of service in the world you know I
want to be able to be of the best use of
myself you know I want to kind of re
kind of reignite that the joy that you
know it really can be that really keeps
us warm that kind of operates inside of
us that doesn't matter if you know if
work is going good or if you know we
have somebody that loves us or if we
have a new shirt or anything like that
I want to have that pilot light inside
of me that really that just has a
confidence of comfort and that's one
thing I want to you know if I had a new
year's resolution for myself it's just
to aim towards finding things that make
that brighter and for me usually this
that's gratitude finding things to be
grateful for and people to be grateful
for and uh you know I've been going
through some stuff like you know I've
been in like a you know a relationship
for a while and really you know a really
loving scenario and and it's hard you
know and it's hard when that's not you
know functioning the same way that it
once was and you know it's hard too and
then also you know you want to you know
you want to remain hopeful and you want
to you know you want to UM you wanna you
want to you know it's
it's interesting because you know you
still even sometimes when you're not
with somebody you still want to be able
to love them you know there's something
really nice about being able to love
somebody you know there's just something
nice about being able to just care about
someone not even you know yeah there's
nice things about you know relationships
and you you know you get to do things
together and this and that but there's
such a man it really it really feels
good to care about somebody and this and
to watch someone else feel cared for man
that's such a beautiful thing that we
can get so easily out of the world that
we can do ourselves you know just when
you love somebody and and get to do
loving things for them and want to lift
them up and make them you know you want
to make them see themselves as
beautifully and perfectly as you see
them it's a the reward you get from that
is really that's one of the things that
I want more of in in my life is just
those those invisible but just real gold
rushes of joy that you can get from from
you know just caring about other people
you know and I hope to find ways to
infect that in a more myself this year
because because I think as a species
were you know we're learning that a lot
of this uh these things and this stuff
and this there's not that much value in
it there's not that much strength in it
and uh and that the connection with
others and being vulnerable and willing
you know that's where a lot of joy is at
or that's what I'm learning anyway and I
want to just be able to learn that even
more and I hope that
you know my higher power kind of can
make that a part of my and I hope I can
make myself willing to be a part of that
this year and just you know try to try
to surround myself with those types of
things and those types of inspirations
because I noticed the things that I
spent my time doing are the things that
I become and the feelings that I become
and uh and so I just you know that's one
thing I want to try and do this year
just trying to spend my time doing more
stuff that is in the in the realm of of
joy and onward Ness
then we got some good call that hit the
hotline and if you hear me sipping right
now I'm a sip on something hmm and I'll
tell you what that is man it's that for
sig Matic if we look everybody been
doing coffee for a long time in the
world's changing years ago people didn't
you know they didn't even have uh they
didn't have whipped cream somebody would
just put a bunch of you know throw some
milk on top of something people like
what what the [ __ ] is that guy doing but
now things have changed and people have
new things and before people were
drinking coffee you know you'd have
somebody you have nine cups of coffee
and try to you know pick a lock with his
tongue you know and let a bunch of
Rottweilers out into a name schoolyard
but that's changed and one new product
that's out there is called for fo you
are sig Matic and if you're one of the
64% of Americans that drink coffee daily
you might want to listen to this for sig
Matic these guys have been making
drinking mushrooms a thing since 2012
that's right drinking mushrooms for sig
Matic sells mushroom coffee that
actually tastes great and it's good for
you so you get the same lift you get the
same gift that's in a regular coffee but
you don't get them jitters you don't get
them caffeine K kkkk you know next thing
you over there you know undoing the
ruffles on somebody skirt with you you
know which elbows or something next
thing you know you you so keyed up you
licking your own mustache off your body
but you don't get that with four sig
Matic mushroom coffee has half the
caffeine of regular coffee and it's
truly magical and it doesn't taste like
mushrooms don't get that idea it just
tastes like a tea or a coffee while
these shrooms they won't make you high
they will make you think mushroom coffee
is way easier in your gut and it doesn't
leave you with them and didn't give him
giving him dim dim dim jitters mushroom
coffee has two rock star shrooms in it
lion's mane and Chagga lion's mane is my
favorite functional mushroom I just
can't get enough of it it's your brains
best friend imagine if your brain had a
little sidekick a little side piece you
know a little Fauntleroy running around
with it
that is lion's mane in that Chagga
and Chagga that's not a racial slur or
anything like that it's a winter
necessity it helps support your immune
system and who has time to get sick
these days I don't I don't want that I
want to be working I'm going to be
moving forward well mushroom coffee
comes in easy to use and easy to carry
single-serving packets this one right
here that lion's mane you can see this
on the YouTube and that's that mushroom
elixir from four sig Matic I got a
special offer for our listeners you
receive 15% off 15% off your four sig
Matic purchase go to four fo you are sig
Matic si gee ma t IC dot-com slash
Weekend or use the discount code weekend
at checkout that's four sig Matic comm
slash weekend or use promo code weekend
for 15% off and it is good stuff man
it's hasty it makes you feel like a part
of something new and I like that lion's
mane and I like that Jagga let's get
into a couple calls that came in I want
to thank you guys as always for hitting
the hotline it's nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three I want to
thank everybody that was a sponsor last
year we had so many good sponsors a hood
hat
Bixby coffee we had Yaya's crepes down
there in Louisiana and we had a lot of
small businesses that really helped
get vibin all right so today's episode I
wanted to focus on just thinking about
you know fellas and us moving forward
you know cuz a lot of men right now it's
a really tough time out there and it's
tough for women too
I know that but you know well I guess
look I don't know if it's tough for
people I guess I just know that it
sometimes it's tough for me you know
it's tough to know we're in a different
time we're in a transition period in the
world in some ways and we're just
evaluating a lot of what's going on you
know there's a lot of evaluation going
on at the US border there's a lot of
people chiming in about how they feel in
different people and this is and this
point of view and this point of view and
there's a lot of point of views out
there so you know what I'm learning for
myself is I got a ten the sheep that I
can touch and that is obviously a term
from probably Indiana or Alabama but you
got a ten of the sheep that you can
touch and and we just have to you know
as men sometimes we have to share our
experiences so that we can learn from
one another and make good choices as we
move forward in all aspects of our life
and with some of us some of those
choices we learn from ladies some of
them we learn from each other and a lot
of them you know uh you know we just
have to be able to continue to
communicate with one another I think
let's take a call that came in right
here here we go doing Gang Gang brother
homeward didn't know I sure about this
thing that I have I get a little bit
interest in a girl
on the next day I mean on the next day
when we arranged a date
we're like arrange it for the day after
and when the day comes that morning I
don't feel like going there you know I
mean but I just lose interest I have no
idea but the thing is okay so you lose
interest you you'll set up a date and
then the morning of the date you'll lose
interest okay let's hear more night
before I'm like I'm like out for it the
next day I always find the reasons to
postpone it
so wonderful years you have something
similar similar experience with the
ladies thank you for calling brother
I'll tell you it is now I used to set up
a lot of dates in my 20s and then the
night before I would you know jerk off
or do masturbation's and when I was
doing masturbation man I would the date
was done I wasn't going on a date the
next day because I'm a real you know I
got that heavy flow aunt Flo's in town
when I masturbate you know so I really
spray out I mean I lose probably 2% of
my body weight you know I'm you know I'm
that real that frother you know what I'm
saying I'm that you know I'm really
exposing some seed when I do it so I
would be exhausted you know I'd almost
have to be in a damn you know get a damn
IV or something - Rico agya late you
know get the fluids in me so I can I can
relate to that because I would do that a
lot I would have a date set up the night
before I get hopped up on pornography
and do myself out with my you know then
hey you know that hands up so yeah I can
relate to that man but it sounds like
let me see if you're setting up a date
with somebody and really what I was
doing I think was for me it was just
about fear I was afraid how the date
would go I think I think I was afraid of
you know is this girl gonna like me is
it's gonna go well what's gonna happen
and so I would just get so keyed up I
would jerk off and then I didn't want to
do to date and it was probably a control
issue I knew that if I jerked off I
would feel good and I wouldn't leave it
up to this girl and whether or not she
would accept me or not you know that's
what I think it was moral for me I
didn't want to go before a girl who I
felt you know a lot of times what women
thought of me determined what I thought
of myself and so I didn't want to go
before a woman and have her judge me
negatively because I just knew how much
that was gonna make me feel
bad about me so instead I would cut all
of that off at the pass by just you know
doing that mass tea at the house doing
masturbation's and then that way it
would give me an excuse I'd be like oh
well now I'm tired so imma cancel the
date and it kept the power you know the
control it kept it on you know I was in
control of the situation so for me it
was a control issue you know it was like
well if I don't go on the date then I
don't have to be subjected to the
judgement and I and I felt so bad about
myself I was like there's no way this
girl's gonna like me but now another
thing it could be lazy and then maybe
that's just your something you can try
to put on yourself maybe just try to
have a new experience with dating
because these are the golden years I
feel like of us enjoying each other as
humans man it is so quick that
everybody's locked into their iPads and
this and that so it's different brother
you know but I think you try yours maybe
you just try to have a new experience
you know I'm gonna go on a couple of the
dates because these are people that
agreed to the time you know in it and
sometimes when we make agreements to be
somewhere for somewhere and do something
and then we don't honor it you know for
whatever reason we it's just a selfish
act really it's saying oh we don't think
enough of them to honor their time you
know to honor the fact that they might
have set aside their evening to spend
time with us and then maybe you don't
think of it as a date maybe just think
oh here's a new opportunity to meet
somebody new and maybe make a friend or
something you know and I know friend
doesn't sound as cool but these days
friends is [ __ ] each other so if
you're looking to do sex you could get
that opportunity out like that but I
wish you well with it man and I
appreciate you calling losing interest
the day of you know I it's you know
sometime you want to find the goal but
when you get the gold it in which you
were really looking for
so maybe you're looking for somebody but
you know there's something else maybe
you're not maybe try a man's bra set up
a date with a man's and see if you show
up for that one
then you might learn a lot about
yourself but good luck to your brother
man I love you all right the hotline is
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three let's take another call
what's up Cameron from Michigan and you
guys basketball team is doing well the
big blue and and that's good and people
say Michigan is a good a good place at
winter time you can do a little bit of
hitchhiking up there I heard it's one of
the last decent American hitchhiking
hotspots is up there so let's hear more
sometimes I almost year and thank you
thank you looking around down there with
her ex-boyfriend she says not a thing
but okay you've been seeing a girl you
think she's messing around on you with
her ex-boyfriend let's hear more you
know hanging out here and there taking
calls saved mine with Jesus and Satan is
and she's with me so just wanting to get
your input on the matter man Gang Gang
brother well you know it depends on what
their relationship is I don't think it
actually I don't think it matters what
their relationship is you know I think
it matters what y'all's relationship is
and what's your relationship with her is
it good is it a little suspect I mean at
a certain point in a relationship I
think it's okay you can say hey you
talking and I don't make me doesn't not
make me feel comfortable do you still
have some feelings for this man if
they're still hanging out you know
somebody told me that straight people
don't hang out together and let's take
thinking am i [ __ ] run and I don't
know if that's true or not I'm just
saying it cuz I heard oh oh a man and a
woman they don't you
hangout unless they're thinking about
sex now there are exceptions to the rule
like I have a friend of mine who does
fitness she's a fitness trainer and
we've never had any inkling like that
and she's uh but you know but she is a
friend so I think those lines are
becoming a little bit more you know
blurry these days but if you're thinking
it's it's happening then it could be
happening uh so I would ask her or do a
little you know put a little bit of
flour on the ground and see if she goes
over to his place see if there's
footprints in it you know that's kind of
a tricky thing to do a whole flour trick
do who you [ __ ] flour trick but I'd
ask her and are you afraid to ask her
you think you think she might tell you
well I do like him but if you have some
instincts man your instincts are so
powerful they're really really usually
our instincts are really well cab
calibrated unless there's something
wrong with us which could also be the
case let's hear another call hey there a
mark Happy Holidays to you man and I say
Merry Christmas but I also say Happy
Holidays sometime I say both let's hear
more you know it's the holidays and
people are a few extra pounds oh yeah
and a lot of people they might have a
mini muffin herself you know I know this
beautiful girl she always talking about
how she have a couple mini muffins every
now and then I said what what is that
some girl like get up in the middle of
the night and they have a little bit of
Menem you know they have a couple of
little mini muffins and women like a
little snack you know I saw this girl
she's to get up in at night and fill her
jaw jaw with a bunch of skittles and go
hard like that on the rest of her sleep
just rainbow and up just copped up on
that [ __ ] glucose so women are wild
if you leave a snack in the room
sometime if you go hot a little uh
you know some petit fours or some mom
you know some little sugar snacks or you
know beef Jerky's if you hide us some of
those in the corner and a you know and a
leave them on the counter at night like
for Santa but a lot of time you know
hungry later we'll get over there and
snack NIM matches out so women like a
real they like a secret snack but yes
people are eating more this time of year
let's hear more not only just due to her
eating gosh I think it's that she
doesn't need the right thing okay so you
say your fiance's been putting on weight
and it's not maybe not that she's eating
a lot but she'll need to write things
homeward she doesn't she doesn't
exercise at all hmm
and when we met her out like six years
ago she was on an old book 20 but slowly
over the years
muffin after Buffy you know she's put on
with you and I will say that she will
not eat vegetables do I swear can i
couldn't summon I can summon tears from
her if I made any green beans and that's
happened before damn and she's an adult
because adults we got to take care of
ourselves so you got to have a green
bean every now and then you can't be
having muffins only adult don't eat
muffins only adult or evolved creatures
that eat multiple things but if you're
saying that she doesn't want to and if
you try to force her to yeah that might
not end well let's hear more is there a
nice way that I can motivate her to
either eat better or possibly get some
exercise that mmm I've tried before and
it never ended well for obvious reasons
and any any advice that appreciated
thanks brother thanks for the call
man you know first it's harder for us to
ask somebody to do something if we're
not doing it you could say for health
reasons and a lot of times I don't know
what your age is if you guys are only 19
years old and it's gonna hard to be for
like for health reasons but if you're in
your 20s or you know you're 30 then you
could be safe for health reasons I would
like to us to try some new uh you know
dieting or fitness techniques what do
you think about that I think you got to
put yourself in the mix in the equation
because then it's easier you know
everything is easier to do if we have
somebody to do it with you know in a lot
of us it's like we're just hurting and
we want somebody to come along and say
hey I want to help you do this or I want
us to do this together and not even tell
them that the the benefit is gonna be
there's really you know you could I mean
it's a real selfless thing to do just to
say hey you know I want to try this
stuff what do you think about trying it
with me I would love it if you would try
it with me then you just put it all on
you like I want to do these things what
do you think investor and vegetables are
getting good back in the day they had
like two kind of vegetables and then
things as fasting Brussels sprouts and
more Brussels sprouts I think but now
they got you know zucchinis and bug and
you know cauliflower somebody's [ __ ]
burned a bunch of cauliflower the other
day and sold it to me for about $11 and
I ate that [ __ ] but they have a lot of
different opportunities now and snacks
so I think you could try to have a new
experience with some of those but
whatever you do man do it lovingly
because we all have weird bodies you
know I got hair on my butt and sometime
I walk out of the room backwards you
know I remember when I was dating a girl
in college I would get scared because my
hat I didn't want nobody singing you
know hair on my butt because if people
see hair around your butt
a lot of time they think you know you
don't have you don't come from a good
lineage or your family's kind of like
prehistoric or you know you can't really
afford to get like your you know your
but kind of permed or straight you know
gel down or whatever so I would just be
scared so I whenever I would be in if I
would be you know doing you know
involved in some sort of sexual or full
sexual with a woman then I would walk
out of the room backwards so they
couldn't see my button like I was a
straight up Michael Jackson of uh
fornication you know and so that was you
know we all have those things about us
you know about our bodies we don't like
you know and especially as men it's
tough because you know is everybody's
getting their whole body pruned and
people's getting Nate you know their
Junction pierced and everything and all
of this [ __ ] you know people getting toy
trains installing their ass and all kind
of stuff that things have changed man
people you know some women they'll get
their breasts you know removed and then
repurposed up around their shoulders
like damn you got some [ __ ] milk
dripping out of your damn you know up
near your clavicle mama but people are
changing we got to be aware but I think
whatever you do man try to do it
lovingly you know and also know what
you're getting into you know I have a
friend and he's married and his wife
he's at this point in their marriage
he's like my wife does this and this and
this and I said would you know she's
probably doing those things when you
married her and she didn't like doing
she didn't like go if she didn't like
fitness and you know it maybe then you
can consider is this you know what I
want but good luck man it is a tough one
but whatever you do do not say something
that is gonna hurt somebody's feelings
cuz those things are hard to change or
do your best not to man you know [ __ ]
what do I know man
next call coming in here nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three and I
appreciate uh you know young men calling
in with things that are going on this
episode is about it really is kind of
about what's going on with some men
let's take a call here homeward what up
the other was Connor Connor from South
Carolina and you know I went hitchhiking
one time I was in love with a woman and
I hitchhiked up to South Carolina in
Charleston and I showed up in the middle
of the night and I found myself on my
ex-girlfriends porch I was petting they
had a cat out there and I pet that
little [ __ ] probably for two hours for
hours or something you know and uh right
till the Sun was come just starting to
come up and I don't I don't pet a cat at
sunrise I'm not that kind of guy you
know I'll do so I've done some things
and you know almost got caught in
something once but thankfully I had to
go to the airport and you know cuz this
dude had locks on his bathroom and [ __ ]
was weird but what I'm saying is this
you ain't gonna catch me Pat and I and
why don't know at sunrise
cuz that ain't the kind of [ __ ] I'm into
you know I'm saying I'm trying to go to
heaven not other places she won't catch
me petting a damn animal I don't know
very well at sunrise you catch me doing
natural stuff at sunrise having an
orange juice you know getting um you
know reading a poem doing you know going
back to sleep doing regular [ __ ] you
gonna catch my hand on the back of a
[ __ ] animal I don't know very well at
sunrise bruh and if you see somebody
doing that [ __ ] shut them down notify
the authorities if you see something say
some but what else do we got here on
word from South Carolina homeward I was
calling and having some marital issues
went through a lot of like physical
abuse mental abuse when I was child and
I'm kind of a loner my wife does I don't
communicate enough just wondering what
your thoughts are about it let me know
thanks for calling man and I'm sorry
that you had that time when you were
young and you know but I think it's
brave you not to let that time just
define you forever
and that's one of the things I'm where
I'm at in my life too man it's like am I
just gonna always live in these little
circles where I keep doing [ __ ] because
of you know things that happen to me or
am I gonna cruise up past this am I
gonna draw the line and get to that
other side it's really hard man to
communicate with people when you when
you probably weren't communicated too
well as a youngster or when the
communication you needed and the way you
needed it didn't come in to you that way
because when you're young and that
happens to you it makes you feel all you
think is or all we think sometimes or
all I thought was that something was
wrong with me
you know if the world doesn't feel okay
if something's wrong in the world then
it's must be my fault because as a
youngster we think the world revolves
around us it has to it's the way we
learn to live in it but I think yet man
you know I was struggling with this and
and I still do sometimes and uh you know
sometimes it can be just say I'm scared
to talk about how I really feel
sometimes because you're probably scared
that if you do even though you might not
realize it until you say it you're
probably scared that if you share how
you really feel that your spouse may not
love you or they're gonna think a way a
certain way they're gonna judge you or
make you feel a certain way where then
you're gonna feel ashamed of sharing
because sometimes that at a place where
we don't even remember anymore
we were afraid to share because it
wasn't safe and I know that sounds bruh
honestly low-key like some gay [ __ ] but
about Heike it doesn't you know and if
you're sitting there with her you can
say look I don't want to share things
with you and she's gonna say why and
there's gonna be feelings in her come up
and you're gonna it may be hard to say
whatever you're gonna say but you need
to say whatever that next thing is
and sometimes that next thing is well
I'm scared or I'm ashamed or I'm
embarrassed or and it's not even about
her it's just about some other way that
you uncomfortably learned or we're
trained not to communicate in the past
and it's just it's gonna resurface
itself until you feel comfortable but
man sharing those nightmares that are in
us and sometimes those fears and and
just being just being brave to say hey
look I don't know why but it makes me
feel bad that I can't share with you
it makes us it can eventually lead us to
some relief but but if you're thinking
about it man that's a cool thing to be
thinking about I think and that's I
appreciate you call them because that's
right in line with some of the stuff I
want to try to get through some of this
year you know but Gang Gang brought home
word let's take a call right here that
came in good luck over there in South
Carolina man
and those Gamecocks in clumps climp son
playing tomorrow night and I was in
Charleston South Carolina when 9/11
happened and I went outside and I was
doing construction work outside and I
thought something happened locally and
then we went and got us a kick and kick
in onward ATO this is Luke Keene calling
from Charlotte North Carolina
Luke King from Charlotte miss
Charlotte's a very diverse city in a
city that's on the on the rise but it's
also kind of a milquetoast city in a lot
of ways it's also kind of calm
I'm a unique place a lot of banking and
I saw Cameron Cameron Diaz who's the
quarterback Cameron Fowler nope Cameron
Newton pushing a baby stroller there one
time when I got there and he was in a
Gucci hat homeward I've been dating this
Russian girl oh now that's the dark arts
bra for about about a year now and
anyway a couple of my buddies thought
it'd be funny to text her from my phone
and say that I wanted her to eat my back
door out oh okay so you talking about
getting her getting back there and
having that little lavender snack huh
you talking about her getting back there
and having a little bit of uh you know
that you know sucking on that dirty
go-gurt more and I'm not into that kind
of stuff but I had no idea they sent the
pic in anyway we just gotten out of the
shower and I was laying on the bed
stomach down looking at my cell phone
what bro I don't believe this [ __ ] you
were laying on your bed stomach down
looking at your cell phone
who are you Eve in the Bible D nobody
doesn't [ __ ] dude but you know doesn't
[ __ ] people that's about to get
straight-up molested bra or something
somebody that's about to get bit by a
wolf dude where do you live at Narnia
you let's hear more and the whole let's
hear that again we just gotten out of
the shower and I was laying on the bed
stomach down looking at my cellphone and
what little did I know she came running
up behind me and leaked onto the bed and
just started going to town
what dude where's your girl where's your
girlfriend uh what species is she that's
my question because you know nobody just
runs up behind you
leaps onto the bed and start snacking on
that little you know on that little blue
jean baby you feel me on that brown-eyed
girl and if you don't know brown-eyed
girl is a song about but you know doing
but activities because hey where did we
go days when the rains came down in the
hollow playing a new game laughing and a
runnin hey hey brown-eyed girl and
that's what that's about doing bottom
stuff homeward and you know I know North
Carolina's first in flight and
everything but I'm just not really sure
how to feel about it well look dude look
here first in flight Lewis and Clark you
know Orville and you know Redenbacher
whoever [ __ ] flew the plane bruh
sound like you if you're laying on your
on the bed stomach down on your cell
phone but then you need to tighten up
cuz that ain't normal [ __ ] dude that's
some kind of [ __ ] that may be like um
you know Geno Smith would do or who's
like a kind of a tender gentleman um uh
you know Stephen a Smith he sounds he
seemed like he would do that [ __ ] that
soft guy from the who else man uh I
don't know somebody else but [ __ ] get
up and if you dude don't stand around
with your ass to people and lay down
like you're like you're in a damn you
know little little women novel or
something let's take another call that
came in onward hey what's going on to
you I was Trevor out of southeastern
Kentucky thank you for calling Trevor
homeward i reasoning injuries at work i
was a Malamud for a power company oh
hell yeah dude I got look I got
electrocuted about 14 months ago bro got
[ __ ] shook down I stepped on some
cable by food truck and they was doing
these lobster rolls and I found out
later they was doing the illegal they
had a legal shellfish going on but I've
been through some [ __ ] like that let's
hear more I got electrocuted at 7,200
volts [ __ ] damn brother who's gonna win
the Superbowl
dawg you took in that many votes bruh
wow you're like a damn washer/dryer
that's a lot of votes man do you should
go do some oral sex or something in the
circus run
you could probably rearrange somebody's
DNA strands with that kind of tongue
work if you got that much volts in you
Jesus man you could make a regular car a
Tesla bra you could get a Jeep Cherokee
and just put your hands on the wheel and
just [ __ ] suddenly you're getting
those that Tesla kickback from the
government that's 6200 or whatever
wow you a real electricity daddy you
know I'll [ __ ] shake your hand him
and uh you know and just and just finger
start a go-cart bra you got that magical
sauce in you let's hear more I kind of
missed my arm up my my heart up a little
bit man and a fire against uh so now I
got a little girl so while I'm trying to
take care of starting to get the praise
man have some anxiety and stuff like
that I never had to do ain't never been
dealing stuff like this before so just
trying to see you know what advice you
had about it and what I can do to get
back up on the up-and-up you found Gang
Gang man I appreciate you calling in and
uh yeah I can hearing your voice is a
little tough and especially if you got
that family you know I noticed this man
is you know I was in you know I've been
in accidents and stuff over the years
and different things have happened and
you know sometimes [ __ ] just happens and
you can still have a claim and you can
still kind of keep thinking you know you
can see if things will hurt down the
road but sometimes you got to let it go
you got shocked up maybe some man some
magic could happen to you in the future
because of it you know it's like I just
mean in the sense like sometimes if we
have like a workman's comp we do that
kind of stuff
you know where we we have like a lawsuit
or that kind of thing it's like you know
those things drag out for a long time
and sometimes they're very necessary but
if you think inside of yourself you know
I'm just I'm worried that you know this
might be long continuing but if you can
get back out and work you know take some
appropriate time you need and get back
out there you know just don't let the
disability to become you
you know they had dudes you know we had
a guy when I was young he didn't even
have any legs right I mean he might have
had him but he didn't show them to us
and he could swallow um tenedor
silverware he could swallow a damn
silverware bra and you'd look at the
dude and you'd be like what the [ __ ] man
I don't think he could do it but then he
would do it and it probably wasn't safe
for him I mean the dude already lost his
damn legs he's out here [ __ ] you know
chewing on knives and [ __ ] and forts you
know sounds like a not a good idea but
at some point he's just got to move on
he could lay up there in the leg shack
or whatever forever you know saying hey
you know I got this and this happened
and this happen but at some point he
said you know what I got to get in the
chair and just wheel out the door and
get back into the working world and next
thing you know he's out there you know
swallowing silverware and you know three
or four piece sets and doing good work
so that what I'm saying is sometime it's
just that thing if you if you you may
have you may have an injury and it may
be a real injury you know and and it may
take you some time to heal from it but
you also have to decide for yourself
well is it worth it to sit and think
about this healing all the time and get
caught in that whirlpool of like you
know maybe having a lawsuit and all of
that or is it worth it just to kind of
get it together and get back out there
and work because
in the end sometimes the finances are
the same like you can you know you can
go to all the you know a lot of times
people get in a car accident they go to
all these things and they do the doctors
and next thing you know you go on a
magical [ __ ] and they got specialty this
and that and it's been six months and
you ran up this hospital bill and it
gets settled by the insurance you get
after everything you make you know
twenty thousand but if you'd have been
going to work the whole time you know
made twenty five thousand so it might
take action you know I don't know man I
know there might be some tough love
stuff to say but you know it's like what
circle do you want to swim in do you
want to if you if you if you're able to
move and able to work some time just
chalk it up and be that [ __ ] magic
dude that got you know keyed up and lit
up by the lower by the damn electrical
cuz look man I've had six friends and
been hit by [ __ ] lightning and if you
don't think for once that I don't think
that lightning is looking for me you're
dead wrong daddy I know it is so when I
meet a new friend now I [ __ ] low-key
if I can slide them a little note I
don't want him to hear him I don't want
to say it out loud because I don't want
the powers that be in the world to hear
us the electrons or whatever I say look
daddy
you know don't look at the sky with your
mouth opening because that [ __ ] really
gonna hurt you might get chopped out
let's take one more call here we go on
this man up episode homeward hey deal
this is landed that I am 35 years old
working as a musician on one of these
cruise line [ __ ] ships or whatever
which oh I like cruise ships do because
I like endless pineapple chunks in the
morning let's hear more which is a good
gig I get paid good and all that stuff
I'd [ __ ] all that anyway the reason I
called is because I actually have been
seeing this girl she was like a big
crush of mine I met her on the boat and
then she left her boyfriend and then and
then we started hanging out by a bit
kind of bloom into this like friendship
thing which are kind of made a
dedication to like just be friends
first you know before we got too crazy
into the sex I didn't want to be a
rebound I [ __ ] want to be with the
one you know I mean like I want to have
that I don't know be one yeah yeah man I
feel yeah I mean sex is kind of almost
[ __ ] sometimes dude
and um yeah ohm word you know um anyway
she's just been distant you know I've
been just up and down man and I've just
been doing my best to give her space but
my biggest problem is I'm getting all
this [ __ ] anxiety this is the main
reason I called it's because I'm getting
all this anxiety about it you know
thinking about who else she's dating
meanwhile I'm [ __ ] going out on dates
with other girls I just don't understand
why the [ __ ] I have this this anxiety
and all this [ __ ] around this when I
want it to work but part of me thinks oh
maybe I'm just obsessing too much maybe
I should just like end it I don't know
I've been communicating these things
with her to an extent and she doesn't
seem to buy it which is a good thing but
is there any solutions you all might
have well I'll say this man it sound
like a control thing to me you know you
want to be able to do your thing and
also know what she's doing at the same
time and that's like about control a lot
of times anyway I mean you met her she
was seeing somebody else you know when
y'all became friends and she left the
guy so you know there's a history there
a little bit of just you know her being
a little bit of a wandering when it
comes to lustfulness but I think yet
this bright now seem like you just have
to take care of yourself you know it
doesn't sound like you're gonna you know
it sound like even you know you can't
win her back and who she's dating and
that sort of thing it's really none of
your business if you're dating I mean
you know and if you're being candid with
her are you just being candid with her
so she'll tell you what she's doing you
know and I don't know why we want to
control others sometimes and I'm not
saying that I haven't done it new when I
was in you know when I was younger I
would use all types of controlling type
of behaviors
you know and I still feel bad about some
of them but you sound like a nice guy
and you sound like you're in a good
scenario and if you want a boat dude
you're basically you got kind of
traveling [ __ ] you that floating [ __ ]
like somebody threw a [ __ ] into the jet
stream and that thing is just you know
bouncing around Indian Ocean you know go
from Mexico Guatemala Himalayas you know
North Sea different areas you just
floating along you might [ __ ] somebody
over here you know maybe a nice tidal
wave just throws you into a window and
they got a little you know a nice lady
in there looking to meet somebody a
little saltwater caca Dilla so you got
this you know you're very you have some
freedom right now maybe just try and
enjoy your freedom you know and
sometimes if you're obsessing over
something you can just you know ask if
you have like a higher power just ask
ask your higher power to help you out
just say look I don't want to obsess
about this anymore can you help me can
you hitchhike my brain right off of this
Avenue or even just pray for your friend
if you want to pray for her say hey I
hope she meets somebody great because if
you're somebody great then one day it
could be you see that way you get like a
little backhanded prayer in for yourself
but I got to go to actually uh I got to
go to a dang meeting so but I love you
guys man you know and happy New Year and
this is it we can do it how we want we
can keep some of the past we can get
some we can you know we can cherry pick
some of the future but I believe that
lives are in front of us but I also
believe that we have to do the work to
meet them halfway I really really
believe that you guys be good to
yourselves I'll see you in Omaha this
weekend 980 five six six four nine five
zero three is the hotline as always
thank you to everybody that communicated
and reached out thank you to our
sponsors for this episode for sig Matic
and skill share and as always you can
you can check us out on iTunes please
subscribe if you haven't get that hitter
and be good to yourself man you guys
deserve it I know you do it's gonna be a
crazy year bro what could happen who
knows I hope that lightning don't give
me
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far from my
home and my mind is somewhere else but
when I found it our patch up where it's
been grown now I'm just floating on the
breeze and I feel I'm falling like these
leaves I must be
[Music]